if I say for example hey Marik nice
haircut right that's a compliment right
that's a compliment but it's not this
compliment how do you spell that
component when you say hey you did a
really great job you spell it within
with an eye very good so this is not
complement with an eye here right not
complement which is yeah you did a great
job when we say complement with an e
yeah it's things that go together things
that go together that's the sort of
overall meaning right so I think we
should say down here right the overall
meaning is these are things that go
together and that can mean different
things in different contexts so let's
just write that down first things that
go together okay now as in example the
sort of most well-known like culinary
food example is people say you might
have a particular meal and then there's
a complimentary wine like a particular
drink its flavor matches really nicely
with this right so for example you might
have a food and drink combination and
like I don't actually drink wine myself
so I can't give you a good example but
red wines go with some foods white wines
go with others right so you might say oh
these complement each other really
nicely they go together
okay I was thinking back to the start of
in fact I was last year but we did have
a look at it this year in geometry this
word complement has a particular meaning
it's about two particular kinds of
things that go together does anyone
remember it's it's a particular kind of
thing with the inner shape wonder
crochet what are you thinking
it's angles very good so complementary
angles right let's just write it down
first and then Jessica I get your
thought complementary angles angles that
go together but specifically what does
that mean Jessica
adds up to 90 degrees so complementary
angles add to 90 degrees so
supplementary is very similar they add
up to not 90 degrees but 180 right so
complementary angles they are up to 90
degrees you might even like to drop down
over here like put a little raining over
there yeah so if I put two angles here
that make up this I'm gonna call them a
degrees and B degrees you can see they
go together and then make something nice
and neat so they're complementary angles
but when we think about probability and
that's what we started looking at
yesterday when we told you a
complimentary events these are two
things that make up everything that's
possible let me say that again two
different events that make up everything
possible okay so two events that make up
all possibilities and I'm going to give
you some examples by the way we have um
we have a word for this or a phrase I
wonder if we Arman counted it before
when we say all possibilities what's our
fancy word for that sample space very
good so I'm gonna write that underneath
so if you've got complimentary events if
you put them together you don't get a
right angle if you put complementary
events together
you've got everything you cover
everything in the sample space so let me
give an example with my first problem
here's my $1 coin it's a 2009 so it's a
10-year old coin okay so right now the
face that I'm holding towards you guys
is the tails side okay that's the tails
face so the complementary event for
tails is whatever makes up all the other
possibilities in this case is one other
thing that can happen if it's not tails
its heads very good so tails and heads
will he'll heads and tails
these are complementary events right if
you didn't get tails you had to get
heads and these are the total
possibilities okay let me give you
another example got another prop here
and we might use this a little bit later
in the lesson so this is a deck of
playing cards okay now I just want to
get a quick show of hands just so I can
gauge you know how familiar you guys are
with this how many of you have like
played a game with decks of playing
cards before hands up I just wonder how
many okay everyone can I get some
examples what games have you played with
a deck of cards brow e speed okay hey
solitaire you're not poker okay so I'm
guard if irately oh okay yeah go ahead
okay thank you hey Lee you know fish is
a classic one more here mafia okay we
can get on and on and on very good I
just wanted to get a sense of
familiarity because you know people play
all games on phones and that kind of
thing so if I picked out an example I
might say and I'd love you to draw this
with me I'm just gonna pick out a card
at random let's say this guy all right
this is the 8 of clubs the 8 of clubs ok
so if we are it's a black card
sorry 8 of clubs mmm
8 what's the clubs look like it's got
those three things at the top right 3
little around and then yeah yeah okay
there's my 8 of clubs is it recognizable
as a native class ok so if you've got
the 8 of clubs and that's one event
right how would you say the
complementary event with that well it's
a little complicated because there's how
many cards in the deck it's 52 so here
I've got one in my hand and the
complimentary event is the other 51
cards right so in this way what I would
say is this it's complimentary event
years or not the 8 of clubs which is not
a very fancy way to say it but that is
the complimentary act cuz remember it's
got to cover everything right it's got
to cover every possibility what if I
took out all of the clubs and I had them
all in my hand so here's the here's the
key of clubs and here's the 6 of clubs
and the queen of clubs suppose I took
out all of the clubs and I just said
here they are in my hand ok here's one
possible event ok what would be the
compliments of the clubs
what's the other thing that's possible
so you don't know what the other three
suits are gone you've got spades the
other black one you've got diamonds and
hearts very good so if I said here we go
one more underneath here stay with the
same color mm-hmm if I said that clubs
was one event so I'm just gonna say
clubs then it's complement would be all
the other things so it would be or what
do we say spades so that's like this
sort of spiky looking one there we go
diamonds and hearts right so you've got
another way of saying all of the
different possibilities the important
thing is when you have a look at all the
other things you've listed right that
should cover everything in the deck of
cards or everything on the coin or if I
said the weather like a weather event
might be sunny it's sunny today right
what would be the complement of sunny
now it's tricky right you know you can't
say you can't say rainy because it can
be not sunny without there being rain
right so you might say cloudy or night
so I guess we'd say it's something like
this right
it's either sunny or not sunny okay
now just one more thing underneath this
so that you've got a way of writing this
because it's nice to have examples but
we also want the notation so if I've got
the probability of some event P for
probability E for event because we use
this all the time what we would say is
that the complement of E is that letter
A with a bar across the top so I'm gonna
write this a and then I'm gonna put a
bar across the top that means not a you
could use the words not a but you know
us mathematicians famously lazy we're
always searching for a faster way to
write things okay